I am shocked about last night yikes
family dinner is getting real heated on
next week's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Corian Scott at each other's throats
over how to discipline Scott and
Courtney's daughter Penelope and a
reminder Penelope is 7 yeah kind of
crazy right this all goes down after
Penelope seemingly or hypothetically
scratches someone and Kris Kourtney and
Kim are all at the table watching or
trying not to watch Kim tweeted out the
clip writing quote next week is the most
intense obviously a lot to unpack here
first this is super uncommon for Corey
to get into a heated fight like this
though back in May Khloe wasn't 100%
onboard with Corey mostly because we
know him to be a pretty quiet Tang in
the background type of guy Corey does
tend to be pretty secretive so me and
all of the kids we just we've been more
on guard with Corey
at the end of the day the family stands
together were United we're there for
each other weak there's a lot of love
there we also don't know how court and
Chris feel about this all that Kourtney
says in the clip is I am shocked about
last night listen I think the real part
is life is a challenge and if you work
at what you want you can get it but it
takes hard work simple as that you can
easily live less of a life without
working as hard and that's a few minutes
hard work for all parties et sat down
with Scott and Chloe pretty recently
where he talked about co-parenting with
Kourtney a reminder they are also
parents two sons Mason and rain yeah I
think you just gotta figure out really
what's important to you at the end of
the day I mean there's so many different
things that could pull you in different
directions and you could look online and
Instagram social meaning all these
things but at the end of the day I mean
you just want to be happy you want to be
content you want to be comfortable even
close
praised the pair for how they co-parent
they're doing amazing and I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
and love is love and I'm so proud of
them it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that hey men Chloe always the voice of
reason all right guys that's it for
today if you want to keep keeping up
with the kardashians make sure you stick
with all things ET until next time I'm
Katie Krauss and bye for now